[Music]
now we also have season 9 is in the
pipeline yep going it now are some of
these changes going to trickle over
there we switch it up all the time on
the show you know we are a roomful of
gay producers and we're very very
imaginative okay
eg was on the set of RuPaul's Drag Race
Season and 9 over the summer and now we
know who will be stomping that runway
when the show returns this year logo
released the first promo for the new
season it's time to meet the Queen we
need America's next drag superstar now
more than ever
there's Asia from Brooklyn
Alexis Michelle from New York Charlie
hides all the way from the UK she does
11 person Asian book now she is selling
fast [ __ ]
then there's Eureka O'Hara from
Tennessee pheromone get it from Las
Vegas James at Mansfield from Wisconsin
and Kimora black another gal from Vegas
moving on meet Nina Bo Nina Brown from
Atlanta and here's peppermint from NYC
next up Sasha velour of Brooklyn then
there shake away from Chicago
Trinity Taylor from Orlando and finally
Valentina from LA so now that you've
seen a little of all the gals in action
who are you rooting for let us know in
the comments you should have your eye on
me I'm the queen to watch the real
winner of every season of RuPaul's Drag
Race RuPaul
[Music]